le délibéré ne faisait guère de doute
nécessaire eddine ben abdelkader a été
déclaré irresponsable sur le plan pénal
par la chambre de l'instruction
cet homme d'une quarantaine d'années
était suivi de longue date pour
schizophrénie paranoïde
les psychiatres étaient unanimes il
était dès lors impossible de le juger
comme un accusé lambda c'est un cas qui
est très très très lourdement atteints
il a évidemment des moments de calme des
moments de où il est stabilisé mais ce
jour là effectivement il était en crise
donc son discernement selon la formule
légale et est abolie en tout cas on peut
le considérer les experts ont expliqué
pourquoi ne pouvait pas considérer que
au moment des faits il ait eu toute sa
tête pour parler également le 21
décembre 2014 nécessaire eddine ben
abdelkader prend sa voiture et fonce sur
des passants dans quatre rues de l'hyper
centre de dijon lors de son arrestation
il crie les propos religieux extrémistes
mais la piste de l'attentât et très vite
écartée par les enquêteurs le passé
psychiatrique du chauffard refait vite
surface
c'est d'ailleurs désormais au tour des
médecins de prendre en charge cet homme
sa détention provisoire a été levée une
longue hospitalisation l'attend de plus
la chambre de l'instruction a prononcé
des mesures de sûreté à son encontre
dont l'interdiction de paraître en côte
d'or pendant 20 ans il a également été
condamné à payer des dommages et
intérêts aux victimes